[Music]
on this Saturday night the chaos after a
blast at a unan run School in
Gaza the disproportionate deaths of
Palestinian women and children plus it's
just a a a nightmare another nightmare
concern from Canadians in Gaza about a
backlog at the Rafa border
crossing this war is just going to
produce more pain for Palestinians for
Israelis diplomatic disagreement the
Arab Nations at odds with the US neck
guard no-brainer I wore him from you
know 13 to 15 till I came into this
league so the simple safety solution
still not mandated in the NHL it's
really difficult to turn on TV and not
see puppets I don't see how anyone could
think that it's a dying art form how the
ancient storytelling technique is taking
Center
Stage global national with barin Asser
good evening and thank you for joining
us Israel has intensified its heavy
bombardment of Gaza hitting densely
packed areas close to hospitals in the
heart of Gaza an ambulance Convoy on
Friday and now reports an air strike hit
a school run by the UN for displaced
Palestinian children in a refugee camp
penetrating through the fog of war and
sifting through the narratives on both
sides is difficult but what is clear is
Israel's bombardment of Gaza is causing
terrible Bloodshed gaza's Hamas run
Health Ministry says close to 9,500
Palestinians have been killed and the UN
says 70% of the victims are women and
children Israel says more than 200
hostages are being held captive by Hamas
inside Gaza Mike Armstrong has our top
story from Jerusalem tonight and a
warning some of the images in details
and our coverage are
disturbing even as its offensive pushes
forward the Israel Defense Forces are
urging civilians in Northern Gaza to
move South while watching these images
released by the IDF make it appear there
is danger in
moving but the images coming from
journalists on the ground make it clear
staying put is dangerous as well a
doctor at the alifa hospital says an
Israeli strike hit a un run school that
was being used as a shelter killing 15
people this boy says there were three
explosions and that he helped carry a
decapitated
body the Secretary General of the United
Nations said Saturday he is horrified by
a strike on an ambulance video of the
scene Friday showed more than a dozen
bodies the Israeli military confirms it
hit the ambulance but says it was
targeted because it was being used by
Hamas Fighters now in a post on Twitter
Saturday the IDF announced a a 3-hour
window for people to move South safely
on a specific Road it later said that
area was fired on by Hamas to stop
people from
moving now there was no movement on
gaza's Southern border after hundreds of
foreign Nationals were able to leave for
Egypt through the Rafa crossing over the
last few days none crossed Saturday
according to a Us official things shut
down over injured patients that were
being moved to Egypt Hamas was trying to
send injured fighters in with injured
civilians The Crossing was
closed Canadians stuck in Gaza had been
told they might be able to get out
Sunday there's fear that may now be
pushed back and yes so that means AIA
mathor is with her husband and two
children now the people that are on the
list today they're going to have to try
tomorrow again oh God this is just no
know it's just a a a nightmare another
nightmare Global Affairs Canada will
only say Canadians should be able to
cross at some point in the coming days
according to its latest update between
people holding Canadian passports and
their eligible family members it's a
list of about 500 people far Mike
Armstrong in Jerusalem thank you and we
have some breaking news tonight Global
Affairs Canada says it's aware of
reports of two Canadian citizens
crossing the Rafa border with a third
party it's unclear when they crossed and
there were more pleas in Jordan's
capital today to protect Palestinian
civilians US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin was there reiterating calls for
a humanitarian pause while meeting with
counterparts from Arab nations in
Iman as Israel conduct its campaign how
it does it
matters Israel must take every possible
measure to prevent civilian
casualties the UN fears war crimes are
being committed in Gaza and blink's
comments you just heard saying how
Israel does it matters suggests he's
calling on Israel to act within the
boundaries of international law but
blinkin and his Arab counterparts are at
odds over the call for a full out
ceasefire David Aken on the rare open
display of diplomatic
disagreement in Jordan US Secretary of
State Anthony blinkin met with foreign
minister from Arab states in the region
who are pushing for an Israeli ceasefire
this is our position that the ceasefire
is imperative to deal with the
consequences the humanitarian
consequences of this conflict but the
United States Canada and many other
Western countries say they cannot ask
Israel for a ceasefire it's our view
that uh a ceasefire now would simply
leave Hamas in place able to regroup and
repeat what it did on October
7th indeed Hamas which Canada says is a
terrorist organization has vowed to do
just that one of its top officials told
Lebanese TV last week it would repeat
the October 7th attacks again and again
and again the US preference and Canada's
is for what is being called a
humanitarian pause a brief cessation of
military operations We Believe pauses
can be a critical mechanism protecting
civilians for getting Aid in for getting
foreign Nationals out while still
enabling Israel to achieve its objective
to defeat
Hamas but Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu rejected what he
called quote a temporary humanitarian
ceasefire offer until the hostages held
by Hamas are released Lincoln also
praised Arab leaders in the region
saying they have played an essential
role in helping to prevent conflict in
Gaza from spreading but at the end of
the meeting Arab leaders were calling on
the US to push Israel to do more this
war is just going to produce more pain
for Palestinians for Israelis and this
is going to push us all again into the
abys of hatred and dehumanization that
will make killing even more more
acceptable so that needs to stop that's
our priority linkoln is now Bound for
turkey the only NATO Ally that is also a
Muslim majority Nation where protesters
on Saturday were waiting to greet him
David Aken Global
News thousands of people across Canada
held rallies today demanding an
immediate ceasefire in
Gaza demonstrations were held in over 30
cities across the country part of a
coordinated effort by the Palestinian
youth movement hundreds gathered in
Montreal holding signs while waving
Palestinian Flags others took part in
similar Gatherings on Parliament Hill in
Ottawa and in downtown Toronto
today's rallies were part of a much
larger movement spanning across dozens
of cities around the world hundreds of
pro Palestinian protesters took to the
streets of Paris calling for a ceasefire
and similar demonstrations were also
held in London's Trafalger square and in
Washington's Freedom Plaza the flow of
humanitarian Aid getting into Gaza is
extremely slow and it's nowhere near
enough civilians are desperate for clean
water and food and they are now turning
to the Sea doctors say there's a growing
risk of disease in the region due to
poor sanitation and clean drinking water
being so scarce tonight Katherine Ward
explains the risks associated with
drinking sea water and what happens to
the body when the Fresh Water Runs
Out access to clean water in Gaza has
been an issue for years with its aquafer
contaminated with sea and waste waterer
people will drink the dirty water get
exposed to
water get infections and those are the
things that will kill people at much
higher numbers than just absolute
dehydration the UN says many
desalination plants can't run without
power or fuel amid Israel's Siege and
doctors say drinking salt water is a
threat people have a concentration of
salt in their blood of about 3% salt
water is about 3.5% and that little bit
of difference is really important
because the you can't drink salt water
and retain more water uh from drinking
than you pee out so you actually lose
water air temperature humidity and a
person's own level of exertion all
affect how quickly people start to feel
symptoms when they don't have access to
enough clean water people need access to
water every day they need access to
several liters of water per person the
effects set in within hours experts say
a person will start sweating feel
thirsty and if water isn't consumed
become dehydrated that is a serious
Health threat at that stage you're
starting to feel really unwell you might
start feeling lightheaded you're going
to feel extremely thirsty at this point
um people will start drinking whatever
water is at hand it doesn't matter if
it's clean or not Beyond three days
you're going to be very unwealthy at
this point um your kidneys aren't able
to really uh retain much more uh fluid
so your urination will basically stop um
at that point uh the body starts
shunting blood to more critical organs
like your brain and your heart so the
calls grow louder from agencies
including the World Health Organization
and Doctors Without Borders for a
sustained humanitarian Corridor we're
hearing of of people spending hours
looking in shops for bottled water
searching for access to drinking water
wherever they can find it a struggle
with no clear end in sight for civilians
caught in the conflict Katherine Ward
Global
News a devastating earthquake struck the
western part of Nepal killing more than
100 50
people the 5.6 magnitude Quake hit just
before midnight on Friday collapsing
homes and bearing people in the rubble
the government says more than 370 people
were also injured the death toll is
expected to rise as rescue crews search
for survivors it's already Nepal's
deadliest earthquake in eight years
officials say the disaster was also
worsened by poor construction quality in
the remote region and because it
happened while people slept
here at home prime minister Justin
Trudeau's decision to pause carbon
pricing on home heating oil has thrust
the controversial policy back in the
spotlight he's ruled out any further
exemptions despite criticism from the
opposition which has introduced a motion
calling for the freeze to be extended to
other forms of Home Heating a vote on
that motion is going to take place on
Monday our Mercedes Stevenson has more
on this week's episode of the West block
Mercedes far the federal Liberals are
facing blowback for not providing more
carb Urban tax car votes to Regions
outside of Atlantic Canada this week on
the west block I asked employment
Minister Randy baso the only Alberta MP
in cabinet if the policy pivot was fair
we built a pipeline and TMX is going to
get completed and that pipeline uh
disproportionately benefits albertans uh
the Alberta coffers it also benefits the
federal Treasury and so when you have a
a country as vast and and regionally
diverse as ours there are going to be
some policy decisions that are going to
you know take a regional Focus but have
a national impact I think that some
albertans would take issue with the
comparison of TMX being built which is
in the the national interests and and
does not put money into every single
Alberton pocket or or people who are
struggling to pay their bills right now
but the question is the decision to step
back on the carbon tax specifically
versus just creating a separate program
that would help with those heat pumps do
you think that the decision to to do
this back flip on the carbon tax
undermines your argument that it's not
presenting undue financial hardship on
people who are low income and trying to
pay their bills in a time where we're
seeing all kinds of inflation and
difficulty with the cost of
living the short answer is not at all if
we take a look at how the the climate
action incentive program uh applies in
the country where there's a federal back
stop like here in Alberta for example
eight out of 10 families get more money
back from the federal government from
collecting uh the price on pollution
then they actually pay for environmental
groups have criticized the Liberals for
building the TMX pipeline saying it
expands Canada's carbon footprint wo's
interview comes after rural Economic
Development Minister gudy Hutchings
fanned the Flames of the carbon tax
Fallout by telling an interviewer that
the Prairies should elect more liberals
if they want their voices heard on
carbon pricing far Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thank you Mercedes and you can
watch the full interview with the
employment Minister tomorrow morning on
the west block right here on
global the rising death toll from
Italy's floods coming up the aftermath
of storm Kieran as Europe races for even
more wild
weather a seventh person has been found
dead in Italy's Tuscany region more than
a day after the area was hit with
torrential rains storm Kieran swept
through early Friday causing several
rivers to burst their banks around 300
people have been forced to evacuate
their homes while many others had their
water and power supplies cut the area is
now bracing for incoming storm Domingos
which is also expected to bring strong
winds and heavy rain to France Spain and
Portugal more than 500 migrants were
rescued in the Atlantic Ocean just off
Spain's Canary Islands after traveling
from Africa to Europe the Spanish Coast
Guard says two dead bodies were also
discovered on board the four boats and
another two people later died in
hospital Spain's interior Ministry says
nearly 31,000 undocumented migrants have
arrived in the past 10 months of 2023 a
111% increase from last year the
European commission president made a
surprise visit to ke today just days
before a key report on Ukraine's bid to
join the 27 member block
morning Ursula V liion was greeted by
Ukrainian president vomir zalinski on
her sixth trip to the nation's capital
since Russia's Invasion V liion says ke
has made excellent progress toward EU
Ascension which could pave the way for
further talks next month sininsky
meanwhile reaffirmed his stance that
this is not the time to negotiate with
Russia and denied any Western leaders or
pressuring him to do
so a catalyst for change ahead the piece
of safety gear more hockey players are
Str popping on after the death of a
former NHL
player is in rips shot stop the re
scores that's video of Adam Johnson's
first NHL goal in 2019 it was part of a
piece played at the start of several
Elite Ice Hockey League games in England
today showcasing his career highlights
Johnson was fatally cut by a skate while
playing for the Nottingham Panthers last
Saturday
his tragic on Ice death has sparked a
debate over the use of net guards among
professional hockey players more leagues
are now mandating their use but as
Heather uck West explains there are
growing calls for other leagues
including the NHL to do
more it's a simple piece of safety gear
that more hockey players are strapping
on I think it's a good step in the right
direction we should be wearing neck
guards the sanage Predators part of the
Vancouver Island Junior Hockey League
making the equipment mandatory St after
the death of Adam Johnson the former
Pittsburgh Penguin was playing a game in
England when a skate blade sliced his
neck when you see something like that
happen in the fashion that it happened
I've never seen an incident like that in
all my days in playing hockey and in
coaching within days Canada's Western
Hockey League announced a mandatory neet
guard policy for its players as well Neu
guards were already required across the
rest of the Canadian hockey league and
for minor hockey players I wore him from
you know 13 to 15 till I came into this
league so uh it's not going to be too
much change for you know me and a lot of
the other guys but there are still
leagues within Canada where the use of
neet guards is not required including
the NHL Canada's minister of sports said
this week that needs to change a call
echoed by four-time Olympic gold
medalist and Doctor Haley wikenheiser
posting it's time for mandatory neck
protection at every level I think that
safety should be the top priority for
for our Sport and so um if players were
wearing neet guards I would certainly
feel a lot safer for sure um in the
league some players including a handful
of nhlers aren't waiting for a mandate
the tragic loss of a young hockey player
proving to be a catalyst for change
Heather urx West Global News
Calgary pulling back the curtain on
pulling the strings next a closer look
inside the art and the future of
[Music]
puppetry for many of us our first
introduction to puppetry might have been
a little show at a birthday party or
maybe a Children's Program like Sesame
Street or the Muppets but it is so much
more than that whether it's on Broadway
or Blockbuster Cinema puppets are
actually putting in a lot of work
enhancing our modern imaginations Mark
arasol takes us into the fascinating
world of this Timeless art
formy Grand he's pulling me out of the
boat the audience is
mesmerized behind the curtain every hand
movement is precise and characters in
dialogue carefully crafted I think I
hurt myself this performance is part of
the first ever puppet con we passed lots
of things a weekend full of live shows
workshops and events I can't
remember it's all happening in Almont on
onario a community outside of Ottawa
that has become an international hub for
all things puppets it's so pretty here
and a big draw is Canadian puppeteering
icon noren young with her is Gloria the
Gopher from under the umbrella tree we
had a really good time it's a type of
media that is appealing to all ages and
it teaches it
entertains it's can be therapeutic it's
an art that's underestimated I would say
this is exciting puppetry dates back
thousands of years now it's having a
moment from Broadway hits to films like
warhorse Star Wars and the Little
Mermaid puppets are taking Center Stage
it's really difficult to turn on TV and
not see puppets I don't see how anyone
could think that it's a dying art form
cuz puppets are everywhere look at all
these friends we have y'all going to be
my friends in Nashville Megan pus is
performing for kindergarteners at Cree
Hall Elementary Megan is a trailblazer
she's Sesame Street first full-time
black female Puppeteer what do you want
to be when you grow up She Knows
puppetry can entertain educate and
Tackle important conversations my very
first opportunity with Sesame Street was
breaking down racism for kids so Sesame
Street has the ability to take these gy
numerous World issues and bring them
down to where a child can understand
them process them and respond to them
you can stand up through puppetry Megan
hopes to inspire the Next Generation for
years to come Mark carasol Global
News and to learn more about the future
of puppetry watch the new reality
tonight at 7 on
global and that's global national for
this Saturday night I'm faran Asser on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is Bakers Brook Falls in gromor
National Park New Finland and Labrador
we'd love seeing your Canada so please
keep emailing us those photos to viewers
at
global.com and just a reminder Daylight
Saving ends early Sunday for most of
Canada so be sure to turn your clocks
back an hour tonight until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good
[Music]
night